[Música]
los koalas el querido icono australiano
están amenazados en los últimos años los
incendios forestales australianos han
devastado las ya mermadas poblaciones de
koalas en 2022 el animal fue incluido
oficialmente en la lista de animales en
peligro de extinción en queensland Nueva
gales del sur y la región de campera
devorata Bart es un activista koala
también es conocida como la mujer koala
parece que hay una madre con su bebé
el bebé aproximadamente 15 meses
Así que se mantendrá con ella no muy
lejos la fundación de koala Australia no
estima un descenso del 30% de la especie
desde 2018 hemos destruido cerca del 80%
de su hábitat y el 20% restante está
bajo una gran presión debido a la
agricultura las minas de Carbón la
construcción de carreteras entre otros
factores
los incendios forestales de 2019 y 2020
quemaron 12,6 millones de hectáreas de
terreno
más de 61,000 koalas quedaron en medio
de las llamas la fundación Calcula que
hoy quedan unas pocas decenas de miles y
sólo queda el 20% de los hábitats
naturales del koala
[Música]
en el suroeste de sidney en el suburbio
de campbelltown rodea este bosque de
eucaliptos Aquí vive una de las pocas
poblaciones sanas de koalas pero su
hogar está amenazado por el creciente
desarrollo urbano este grupo intenta
proteger el hábitat del koala
he escuchado sobre proyectos de
desarrollo y protección en esta zona y
digo Es verdaderamente un error
deberíamos proteger el hábitat de los
koalas
A las afueras del centro de la ciudad
estoy koala cuelga de un árbol
él es el motivo de la movilización de
estos activistas sus esfuerzos no han
sido en vano a pocos kilómetros de
distancia lograron salvar un corredor de
koalas
a la izquierda una zona ya construida en
el extremo derecho una extensión de los
suburbios de cisne está prevista pero
por el centro se ha conservado una
pequeña franja de bosque que permitiría
a los koalas moverse libremente
el factor más importante para mantener
la población de koalas con buena salud
es que ellos se puedan mover y que no
estén en ambientes sobrepoblados sino se
estresarán y desarrollarán enfermedades
renales leucemia o clamidia
la planilla una enfermedad de
transmisión sexual se está extendiendo
rápidamente entre los animales en 2008
alrededor del 10% de la población estaba
infectada hoy 8 de cada 10 koalas están
expuestos recuperar su población nunca
ha sido tan crítico
en este hospital para koalas casi todos
los pacientes son tratados por esta
infección familiar
la clamidia es una infección
bacteriológica que puede desencadenar
conjuntivitis y afectar también el
sistema reproductor de las hembras y
puede generar infertilidad
la infertilidad acelera aún más la
desaparición de la especie
esta hembra está siendo examinada
se le presta toda la atención ya que
todavía es capaz de reproducirse
en esta ocasión se revisa su oreja
mientras está sedada revisamos el resto
del cuerpo hacemos una inspección
completa El objetivo del equipo
veterinario es rehabilitarla para
reintroducirla en la vida salvaje
este animal lo catalogamos de alto nivel
de conservación es joven No tiene
enfermedades se puede reproducir y esto
aumenta la posibilidad de aumentar la
población de koalas
de los cinco alas que han sido tratados
en este hospital 55 han regresado a la
naturaleza